SANDEEP RAVICHANDRAN:
Cognitive Clouds
is a software development agency
where we build scalable, web,
and mobile products.
RAVINDRA KANCHIKARE: We are
six to eight people strong team
and serve more
than 40 customers.
PRASANNA GOPINATH: We specialize
in transforming simple customer
sketches into complex
software products.
Our mission is to
help our clients
to build fantastic
products keeping the design
at the heart of the system.
That's what we do best.
SANDEEP RAVICHANDRAN:
There are three things
that sets us apart.
We use rapid prototyping to make
sure the product gets launched
to market as soon as
possible by building
a proper MVP for the customers.
We have regular meetings
with the clients.
We also prefer to
overcommunicate rather than
undercommunicate, and make sure
things go according to plan.
And last and not
the least, employees
are the backbone of our company.
We make sure the
basics are strong.
They have good communication.
And everyone can serve
as a manager for them.
RAVINDRA KANCHIKARE: It's
quite exciting working here.
Every day is a great morning.
And then you feel like want to
come to office and then work.
PRASANNA GOPINATH: I've read
about the Google Developers
Agency program on the blog.
Google being Google, we love it.
We were looking for alternatives
for building servers.
So Firebase and Google
Cloud were two technologies
we really wanted to try
out and basically scale
our applications.
The second motivation was the
design sprints that came out
of Google got so
popular that we wanted
to actually tinker with it.
And Google Agency
program actually
helped us getting there.
RAVINDRA KANCHIKARE: We
have seen Google building
great applications, and
then, if we can, actually,
use those tricks and
experience and help
our customers get the
same kind of products.
When we started working
with the agency,
we discovered a lot of
things which we didn't know.
And that was really helpful
for us to build better quality
applications.
SANDEEP RAVICHANDRAN: I believe
that any good development
agency needs to be capable of
solving problems on their own.
How to make [INAUDIBLE]
your company.
But its very reassuring to know
that Google was just a phone
call or email away when
we had any problem and we
needed any suggestion to
use any of the products.
The Google Design Sprint
helped to streamline our design
process.
Our [INAUDIBLE] designs
faster, and also,
which in turn cuts down
costs for the client.
So it made them happy
at the end of the day.
RAVINDRA KANCHIKARE: We'd
start working [INAUDIBLE],
and then all the
four or five people
who was working
on the project has
to sit down and work,
and then immediately get
the feedback like that.
That cut down a lot
of time, and also made
the design quality much better.
We have support e-mail,
and also Hangouts in Google
where we have a
question and answer.
That's a great way to us
ask the right question
and find the solutions for it.
SANDEEP RAVICHANDRAN: As
an app development agency,
trust is an important thing.
Being a part of Google
Developers Agency program
really helped us in building
that trust with our customers.
PRASANNA GOPINATH: I
think having Google Agency
certification and
Google's credibility
adding to what we've
been doing already,
we've been able to gain more
customers around the world
to build next generation
Android applications.